it would look something like this
thousands of planes would fly very high
and use nozzles to inject millions of
tons of light reflecting particles into
the stratosphere it would create a thin
chemical cloud of those particles around
the whole planet blocking some sunlight
from reaching the surface but it also
comes with significant risks and
uncertainties things like Mass famine
Mass flooding drought of kinds that will
affect very large populations a 2016
opinion poll conducted by the Harvard
group doing solar geoengineering
research found that 67% of subjects
support its use Bill Gates is among a
dozen individual donors and 14
foundations backing the First
stratospheric Solar geoengineering
experiment out of Harvard it's called
stratospheric controlled perturbation
experiment or scopex and scientists
still need to decide what chemicals
those particles should be made of are
you kidding me when I was posting this
stuff back in 2012 everyone said I was
crazy and I said one day they'd admit it
and you'd all have to believe that kimt
trails are real
[Music]